10 13 à la base c'est une association
pour se retrouver pour parler évidemment
nos problématiques d'entrepreneurs
l'idée vraiment de ce site c'est de
référencer les établissements et qui
mettent leurs liens directs vers leurs
outils de réservation est comme ça le
client est directement en lien avec eux
[Musique]
le but c'est vraiment que le client soit
en lien direct avec le professionnel
c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait pas
d'intermédiaire on remarque bien trop
souvent qu'on a toujours plus ou moins
des intermédiaires lors de différentes
réservation on a le savoir faire en tant
que professionnel maintenant il faut le
faire savoir aux clients de passer paris
tresa pour être au plus proche de toutes
les maisons des restaurants et des
hôtels de france c'est très simple c'est
à dire que vous choisissez soit une
localisation soit un établissement que
vous connaissez soit une région voilà
c'est au hasard et ensuite vous allez
sélectionnés si vous recherchez une
table à réserver donc en ce moment c'est
pas possible un hôtel lui c'est possible
à une chambre peuvent être réservés mais
surtout aussi la vente à emporter ou à
les choisir votre habit cement vous
allez cliquer sur vente à emporter et
vous allez tomber directement sur le
module de réservation de vente à
emporter de l'établissement